hi everyone welcome to the last session
of a PI data DC thank you all for coming
to my talk I'm sure everyone is very
tired from from this long conference but
it's a it's a real pleasure to have you
in my in my talk today so my name is
konstantinos I am a grad student at the
University of Maryland currently I'm
doing my PhD there at the computer
science department and I'm doing
research on database systems so today
I'm very excited to talk to you to talk
a little bit about the project that I've
been working on over the past few months
on conducting graaff analytics /
relational databases using a system that
we're developing called graph gem and
this is work that I've worked with very
closely with my advisor professor I'm
oldish Pandey so we're all more or less
familiar with a graph data structure so
this is a property graph you have
entities that are the nodes that are
connected to each other through
relationships which are represented as
edges here so as you can see I can
basically just take the intro slide and
turn it into a graph here that would
look like this and this is a graphs are
actually very intuitive that way so you
can very easily understand what what
what the entities and the relationships
in this graph mean and I can also add
sort of extra nodes here if I wanted to
to make this graph more complex and add
more information to it so graphs are
this simple data structure that allow us
to gain significant insight so the way
that we do that is through graph
analytics graph analytics is sort of
this this phrase that is in my title and
you hear about a lot so I just want to
define it what what i mean by graph
analytics is basically the leveraging of
connections between entities in a
network towards gaining insight about
set entities right but also gaining
insight about the network as a whole
overall so using using graph
algorithms which are sort of algorithms
that let that use these connections
between these entities to to learn about
the interactions of these entities in
the network we can we can find out how
sort of the world works in this in this
sort of network that we're working with
so we can learn things about individual
entities that we're interested in but
also about sort of the overall network
as a whole so what's the big deal about
graph analytics why why should we care
about them is the first thing that I
want to talk about as it turns out
graphs come up in a variety of different
domains the first thing that comes to
mind is social networks you have things
like Facebook Twitter or LinkedIn where
you have entities connected to each
other if their friends or if they're
following each other however you can
also find these complex structures in
things like for example the domain of
say biology or genomic genomics you have
protein interaction networks you can
have financial transaction networks
stock trading networks the knowledge
graph that people have been using for
for AI is also a very complex network
the internet the world wide web is a
network of web pages that are connected
to each other through hyperlinks
communication networks citation networks
computer networks it's all sort of you
can find the the network structure in a
lot of different domains and and there
is a lot of value in looking at it and
trying to figure out how things interact
and that's what you do with graph
analytics and so some of the really
quickly some of the very some of the
example use cases that people have done
people use graphs to define that to to
detect financial crimes like money
laundering fraudulent transactions cyber
crime to do counterterrorism you can do
you can also do things like fine who are
the key players in a network for example
let's say you're you want to analyze
your email network you want to see who
are the most important people that other
people tend to the contact more often
and that sort of are in between various
clusters in your graph
things like ranking entities like what
Google does with PageRank also providing
connection recommendations between users
so when Facebook or Twitter gives you
those kind of annoying recommendations
about who to follow or who to send a
friend request to that is a result of
graph analytics also things like
optimizing transportation routes
identifying weaknesses and networks also
you can do a graph analytics have also
found application in medical research
things like disease pathology and also
DNA sequencing so there's these thing
these things are called de bruin graphs
that people use to to do sequencing and
assembly of DNA so lots of different
valuable use cases for graphs so power
graph analytics done currently what are
sort of the types of analyses that
people do on top of graphs there are
various different types of ways that
people analyze graphs one of them the
most simple one is people do graph
queries on them so people search for a
specific node or for a specific sub
graph that they might be interested in
they do graph pattern matching to find
sort of specific patterns that they
might want inside of a graph and so the
this this is sort of one way that people
interact with graphs another another one
which i think is very interesting is
real-time analytics so a lot of the time
people want to people want to see what
happens and they have a dynamic graph
where where nodes are coming in knows
you're leaving edges get formed I just
get deleted and they want to see what
what happens in this graph over time and
they want to sort of figure out what's
going on in in real time so if someone
who is very crucial to the network
leaves the graph then that might be sort
of that might be bad for for the network
or for the applicant specific
application you would want to detect
that in real time so real time anomaly
detection and event detection is also
something that people do also
bat-channel it
the vast majority of graph analytics
happen in batch sort of you have this a
single static graph or instance or
snapshot of a dynamic graph that you
load in and you want to do some analysis
on top of that I like centrality
analysis community detection things that
that I talked about in the previous
slide so most of what we call network
science happens in this space and lastly
people have been doing machine learning
with graphs as well so things like
matrix factorization logistic regression
can be modeled as message passing
algorithms on top of sort of specially
structured graphs and if you're
interested in sort of learning about
more about this space we have a blog
post that a professor deshpande has
written at godet UMD edu slash graphs
where you can sort of learn more about
demystifying graph analytics and it's a
very good blog post so now I want to
talk a little bit about the state of the
art of what systems are out there and
what people are using to do all these
different types of analyses so as it
turns out as I as I told you there are
various different ways that people
analyze graphs use to analyze graphs and
the tasks are two widely varied in some
sense because all of the different types
of analytics that I've mentioned in the
previous slide require different ways to
different optimizations in terms of how
the how the graph is stored and how the
data is stored and how and how the data
is as read in order to do these types of
things optimally right and so of course
as with a lot of things there's no
one-size-fits-all solution to each of
these problems there are systems like
Hadoop spark and relational databases
that that people use for a lot of these
things but those systems have their
trade offs and it's generally a very
fragmented area and there's little
consensus about what the best system is
to use for any given use case so you
have things like specialized graph
databases like a neo4j titan blaze graph
kaylee all these systems are basically
native graph databases where you're
data is stored in a way to optimize for
for graph updates and graph analytics
you have RDF stores that store your data
in RDF triples for for the purposes of
something like a knowledge base you have
this interesting space that's coming up
vote on solutions to graph analytics so
solutions that that have sort of a layer
on top of an already existing database
that allows for easily applying graph
analytics on your underlying data
without you having to do anything to
your data so i will talk more about that
a little bit and there's also the space
of distributed batch processing systems
like giraffe graphics which is a part of
spark and graph lab which are
essentially systems that are very good
at doing distributed analytics on sort
of arbitrary size graphs these are very
scalable systems and they're built for
this but in order for you to be able to
use them you need to take your data and
and do a lot of ETL in order to get it
to that format that will allow you to
load them into your system and then
write your analysis on top of it and
there are many more research prototypes
that my community is looking into
currently and so I wanted to sort of
quickly go through the difference
between these these analytics flows when
you have these systems so for example if
you have a graph database your data is
inherently a graph underneath the hood
and that sort of helps you by by
enabling graph updates in a consistent
and correct manner and also just
directly applying graph analytics on top
of it because it's already a graph right
the second is sort of those bolt on
solutions that I talked about that have
this layer that help you more easily
express graph analysis on data that's
not necessarily stored as a graph but
the system this layer sort of
automatically creates the graphs from
the underlying data store and brings
them up and this is what systems like
these have been doing other systems
the distributed graph processing systems
that I mentioned you have to do a lot of
manual etl interaction with the database
itself and and then manually sort of
store the data into the into these
systems and let let that run so okay so
it's it's sort of a mess right the the
question that is probably on your minded
okay I won't have this simple graph
analysis task in my head that I want to
do just to see sort of what I will get
what should I use so there are a lot of
questions you need to ask or your
organization needs to ask itself
regarding this is what first of all what
fraction of the overall workload is
going to be graph oriented how often are
you going to do these sort of graph
analytics is is just going to be a
one-off thing that you want to do once
or is this something that you want to
run every day or every week every month
maybe do you need graph updates do you
have sort of a dynamic a situation where
you want we're sort of graph updates are
coming in in a in high velocity and you
want to support something like this to
your graph what types of analytics are
required so we talked about the
different types of analyses that that
people do on it do you want to do
machine learning on it do you want to do
a batch analytics or do you want
real-time analytics and how large is the
graph going to be this is a big one
right so if your graph fits in memory
then you have lots of lots of different
options you can use if your graph is is
sort of very large then you need a
distributed system then sort of your
choices kind of get filtered from there
and another thing that I think is very
important is are you starting from
scratch or do you already have a already
deployed database or sort of a flow of
data that's coming in and you like the
way it is it works for you for
everything else that you're doing right
now but you just want to do some sort of
graph and houses on top of that so I'll
just leave you with these questions for
now and go into what what most people
are dealing with right so the first the
first question that I
would ask if I wanted to do this is
where is where is the data that I
currently want to analyze as a graph I
want to see it as a graph and analyze it
as graph so organizations would
typically model the data according to
what that organization is doing right so
you would only use something like a
graph database at least in my opinion if
you if your workloads are strictly graph
centric if you're sort of the Twitter or
Facebook of the world and your your face
sort of analysis is as graph oriented
however most business analytics that
almost everyone does is my is my guess
like querying reporting analytical
processing those things happen in sequel
and the vast majority of the time people
use sequel enabled systems so most
likely your data will be organized in
some sort of a database schema you'll
have at least the at a logical level a
collection of tables or classes that are
related to each other through common
attributes that will call primary or
foreign key constraints so your schema
would kind of look either either like
the one on the Left which is a
normalized schema or like the one on the
right which is like a denormalized star
schema or anything in between and what
you need to do in order to see this data
as a graph you need to extract the
connections and to abstract the entities
so you first you need to define what
what the entities are in the graph that
you want to analyze and what and how
those entities should be connected to
each other right and so as I said most
likely your data is going to be in a
sequel enabled datastore perhaps a
relational database that people have
been using for many years now for for
their very strong integrity and
consistency guarantees and so the the
next thing I want to go into is that
there's a lot of hidden graphs that may
exist so your your your data will be my
assumption is that your data will be on
top of some sort of schema right you
will have a schema even though even if
you're using a no sequel database you
would still have some sort of schema on
it and there was a great talk yesterday
that talked about this a few as we're
there
and so given the fact that there is a
schema right there's a lot of hidden
graphs a lot of different ways that you
can define your entities and the
relationships between them in your data
so let's say that we have a schema like
this this is a variation of the TV CH
database which has a which is basically
which basically describes a data set of
customers that are connected that that
that I've ordered a set of parts and
there's also information about each part
and about the supplier for each part so
let's say that we wanted to create a
graph where our notes are the customers
and we want to connect it we wanted to
connect them with each other in some way
so there's a variety of different ways
you can do that you can say I want to
connect customers to each other if they
bought the same item I want to connect
them if they bought let's say the same
item on the same day perhaps you can go
there or you can say if they've bought
from the same supplier and there's a lot
of different ways you can sort of define
what the connections between those
entities will look like and so well this
is what I call hidden graphs inside of
your data right and you can also define
many there's also many different ways to
define which which are the nodes in your
graph so you can say I might want to
analyze a graph of suppliers if let's
say suppliers sold products in the same
in the same I guess area right ever in
the area with the same area code so if
we if we go back to the state-of-the-art
slide with all these different systems
what I want to do is I want to focus in
on these bolt-on this is the idea of
these bolt-on solutions the idea of you
already have a database that that you
like how your data flows in everything
works you don't want to change that but
you still want to apply some sort of
graph analysis on something some data
that exists inside of there so that's
basically what our vision is for this
system what we want to do is want to
enable this bolt on analytics capability
on top of any database that has a
that has sequel support essentially and
is governed by some sort of schema and
as you saw in in this slide most of the
most of the bolt on solutions that are
out right now are highly proprietary so
the so Oracle solution is significantly
different than SI p solution and it only
works for oracle right and the same for
SI p and terror data and anyone else who
has done this okay so graph jen is the
system that we're building at maryland
and what what grafton does is its its
goal is to enable users to extract and
analyze many different types of graphs I
mentioned many hidden graphs that may
exist in your in your data and we do
this using a simple and intuitive
declarative language that we've defined
based on data log that will enable you
to do this very easily and very fast
without the without the need for you to
do any sort of ETL in order to you know
combine tables in your data manually and
extract the graphs yourself and after
that the system also enables a exposes a
full graph API and a vertex eccentric
framework so that use so as soon as you
extract your graph you can like on the
fly write your analysis task and run
anything on top of it so graph jen has a
bunch of interfaces that you can
interact with one of them is the graph
to an explorer which is a web
application that we've built that is
built towards that is built towards
exploration of these hidden graphs that
I talked about in your data set draft
jen is a natively written in Java so we
also have a native Java library
obviously that you can use and because I
heard this conference is has a lot of
people that like Python we also have a
Python rapper library over this thing so
that you can use it through a Python
script so that's even easier so now I'd
like to go into and show you what the
graph to explore web application looks
like so first of all the the idea of
this of this
web app and why we thought it was
necessary or why it's cool is because it
allows this exploration of your schema
and what types of different graphs may
exist in there that may be interesting
to analyze it allows visual exploration
of these graphs as well as simple
statistics and on-the-fly analysis of
the graph that you want to that you want
to extract and the idea here is that not
all graphs that you might think are
interesting are going to be useful in
the end so for example if you would go
ahead and try to extract a graph of
suppliers that have you know sold their
products in the same area you may find
that this is a completely uninteresting
graph where like perhaps you know
suppliers have all are all selling in in
every area right it's completely
bipartite graph or something like that
so this is what the system looks like if
yeah so first the user can go to the
left and connect to the database so they
can provide their credentials and the
database that they want to connect to
and they click connect so as soon as
that happens the schema gets loaded into
the left hand side so that you can look
at it and see what sort of potential
graphs you might want to to extract and
then you can write your query in our in
our query query language on that box or
generate a query automatically with a
graph enumeration framework that we
built that I'm not going to get too deep
into but in this end a specific video
I'm automatically generating it and then
so after that query is in there and you
click extract what happens is the graph
gets loaded in and you get a visual
representation of a small portion of it
because you know visualizing large
graphs is very is very difficult in
general so what you want to do with this
web app is just sort of explore the
structure how many how many nodes are
connected to each other what are our
they're sort of many nodes that are by
themselves are there you know many
complex connections or is this sort of a
boring graph you can fetch a random
samples of the graph to see what's going
on and also using that text box right
there you can define a specific
predicate to get a graph a specific the
neighborhood the one hop neighborhood of
a specific note that you might be
interested in looking at and you can
also do things like fetch like let's say
fetch the top 20 nodes based on their no
degree and and sort of look at those as
a list so you can do simple queries like
that also on the right-hand side you can
see there are some important properties
of the graph like the number of nodes
the number of edges the density in the
max degree and you can also see the
degree distribution of the notes on on
the right-hand side over there and
lastly using that green box of that
green button on the right-hand side you
can actually serialize the graph into a
standardized format like gml or graphs
on or graph ml and and after that you
can sort of take that file from your
file system and load it into a batch
processing system or network X or
anything else you might want to do with
it so this is what the web application
looks like graph gen pi is a library
that we've built over the system that is
built for usage in in Python and this is
a simple example of how you would how
you would go about using it so it's very
simple you need to simply define your
query in our language define the
database credentials so that you connect
to the database that you want generate
and serialize the graph by calling the
generate graph method and putting in the
format that you want loading the graph
into network x or any other library
graph tool or anything else you might
you might want and then running an
algorithm on it so as you can see with
six lines of code i was able to extract
a graph and run page rank on it so i
think this is very powerful
that this regard and lastly you can use
graph gin and Java sort of the name the
native way to use it which is more or
less the same you you connect to a
database you define your query extract
the graph and then you can for one ways
you can use the vertex centric framework
that we have so if you're familiar with
this framework you define a compute
function and you tell each note what
operations to to to do at each super
step so if you're familiar with the
vertex centric framework you can use
that natively in our system and it's
fast and and and and runs parallel in
your on your machine and you can also
sort of have direct access to the graph
and just say you know for for for every
node give me its neighbors and with that
you can do arbitrarily complex stuff
I'll arbitrarily complex analysis on top
of it yeah so the the the reason you
would use the native Java API is because
you can actually load the the graph into
memory using using this and you're
you're actually interacting with the
graph directly here so this is sort of
why you would go about using our native
Java framework and we have various
optimizations that we've developed as
part of research of this research
project to make to make loading the
graphs as efficient as possible here yes
so the upper limit is is in the is
basically how large your memory is right
it depends on how large your memories
but we have we have various
optimizations under the hood that allow
you to to actually load in graphs that
normally wouldn't fit in memory so yeah
we have a lot of optimizations there but
but the upper bound is always going to
be the size of your memory because we're
loading that into memory like basically
we don't have that capability yet but we
are definitely looking into into into
what we can do with sort of paralyzing
this system but for now this is sort of
how large of a graph you would be able
to load in in memory in one machine and
analyze it and you'll be surprised how
large graphs you'll be able to do that
with so see how I'm doing on time ok so
the just really quickly the backend
architecture of the system looks like
this you have the three interfaces that
I talked about with the system and the
system sort of expects a query and in
our in our language that that query goes
ahead and gets translated into sequel
queries underneath the hood
automatically those queries are executed
against the database the data Gates gets
loaded in efficiently and then the user
sort of gets a handle on on the graph
object and it's simple as that so sorry
so I've been I've been sort of glossing
over this language that we've that we've
developed and I will I will now talk
about talk about the grafton language so
what this language is is a
domain-specific language we've developed
that that looks a lot like data log in
terms of its syntax and the only thing
that user needs to do using our language
is to specify two things how the nodes
are defined in the graph and how the
edges are defined the query is then as I
said executed automatically and the user
gets a handle on a graph object in
return this allows for graphs that have
multiple so it's a we've tried to make
it as expressive as possible so you can
have graphs with multiple different
types of nodes as well as multiple
different types of edges so let's take
an example of how you would write a
query and in our language let's take the
same database that we had before and
let's say we want to explore a graph of
customers what we what we need to do
using the language is we need to see
which of these two which of the tables
in this schema would we need to combine
or in order to extract the notes and the
edges of our
graph so clearly the customers table is
is is what would define our nodes in
this graph and then if you look if we
wanted to say extract a graph of
customers that are connected if they
bought the same item then we would have
to combine the orders table in this case
because that's what sits between the
customers and the parts table so and
this is this table is what has the
information about which customer has
bought which item and then combining
that will give us the graph that we want
so as an example this statement so the
the graph extraction statement for for
this graph would just be to two
statements here the nodes would be
defined by customer table so this
statement creates a node for each row in
the customer table and gives them a ID
and a name as properties and this
statement here combines the the orders
table with itself it does a join on part
key so that the result of this table is
inherently the edge list that we want is
basically the customers that have bought
the same item and so what this says is
connect ID 1 customer ID 12 customer
without e2 if they've both both ordered
the same part in this database so just
to recap what graph jen is is basically
the goal that we have for it is we want
to enable extraction of different types
of hidden graphs that you may have
inside of your data independently of
where that data is stored as long as you
have some sort of inherent schema and
you have sequel support and we want to
enable arbitrarily complex analytics on
top of it using our APAP eyes that we're
exposing to you the second sort of thing
that is more to the research side of
this project is how do we make this
efficient we have various in-memory
representations that we've developed in
order to make the extraction as
efficient as possible that that should
take as little time as possible and
should also take as little memory as
possible so we can have as large graphs
as we can in that fit in memory in
and our analyzable and also we we we
have an efficient parallel execution
engine that you can use to run things on
your one machine for now also the most
important thing I think here for at
least four for everyone here is that
this is this should be very easy right
we've designed this to be effortless so
so you can really easily with two lines
of code define what graph you want to
extract using our language which would
eliminate the need for any complex etl
in order for you to get that graph out
of there and so what the overall goal of
this system is to enable intuitive and
Swift analysis of any graph that exists
inside of your data so you can download
grafton currently at this website which
i also have a very extensive sort of
blog post that will help you use the
language and learn how to how to write
queries on it i have various examples in
there and i also have a blog post at
district data labs which i'm sure you
guys have heard about by now on which is
at that link i will upload the slides
later today and so i am very open to any
sort of feedback about the system please
check it out and let me know what you
think any feedback is is always welcome
email me or tweet me whatever a feedback
you may have or anything you may want
help with and again you can download it
there so that's all I have take any
questions
any questions yes in the other columns
what do you mean other columns so right
now you can define ahead and link that
is if those two records can be too long
right yeah that's that's actually a
really good question so the question was
Kim can you have can you actually also
extract wedge waits for example right or
are properties so using using the system
right now you can't and the reason for
that is is because we're for the
purposes of the research project we're
focusing on being able to sort of load
in these graphs as efficiently as
possible and there's an issue with if
you wanted to do something like also
extract sort of a Greek so an edge
account in that and that regard will be
an aggregation here and we're still sort
of working through the details of how
you would do that as efficiently as
possible because originally would you
would have to extract the entire graph
and we're trying to look into ways into
how you can sort of extract very large
graphs without having to to materialize
all of them so that's sort of more of
the research part of the project and
I'll be happy to talk to anyone about
about this stuff so yeah that's a really
good question and we're going to work on
it any other questions yes
very
different ID so you you can actually
have more than one node statement so you
can sort of have you can say I want
customers connected so I you can have
two nodes statements you can say I want
two types of nodes or customer nodes and
supplier nodes right and you can have an
edge statement that connects those two
so you are able to do that any other
questions
all right yes yeah the underlying
implementation is the right now is in
java and and currently we've what we're
supporting to data or currently we're
only supporting postgres and my sequel
and sequel light sorry but so the
overall vision is that that we're
actually seeing the database here as a
black box right so as soon as long as
the database has a sequel interface over
it then you can use this this system no
problem over you just have to do a
little bit of work for to integrate
different systems and different sort of
sin taxes of sequel basically thank you
that i basically used so i use bootstrap
floor for the for the front end and then
i used d 3 22 for the graph
visualization thank you yeah that's
right back today
tempura so so for the for the Python
rapper and and for the web application
what what it actually does is it loads
the data into because it uses java it
loads it into and to basically the JVM
right so it loads it into into memory
and then because we haven't implemented
a sort of because the system is native
in Java you can't directly access it
through Python you have to serialize it
so in order for you to serialize it you
you you have to basically expand the
entire graph and I'm not sure so you
what was the question again so
everything mm-hmm everything is in
memory in the end the java
implementation yes yes yes I mean the
database the databases is written on
disk but that's about it we're not using
we're not using an intermediate storage
ah and if you have a similar system each
instance if you want to expand
like
yes yes in terms of like the size of the
graph that you want to analyze yes and
that's always talking about sort of a
shared memory system right yeah because
currently we can't do distributed no it
doesn't support the tribute but you can
if you have sort of enough enough memory
you can extract a graph through the
Python wrapper for example let's you
realize it to disk and then take that
gml file file or whatever else format
you might want and load it into
something like graphics or anything else
you might want any plans to use Redis
not it's not specifically but I would be
interested in hearing ideas about this
yeah yeah you said you have plans
sure yes I mean as soon as long as
anything has a sequel interface over it
we we can support it so definitely sorry
if it does it have a sequel interface
layer on them
so you're saying loading in JSON or they
stored where though okay does does a
lecture as elasticsearch have sequel
capabilities now so we could we could
take we could take mmm so the whole idea
here is that our parser translates our
language into sequel so that's that's
the only issue here yeah all right thank
you very much